welcome back to New Rockstars it's me
Tommy B and I've assembled all my
thoughts to roll out this breakdown of
Transformers rise of the beasts this is
the second film of the franchise reboot
and it lays the ground for not only
several new Transformer movies but it
Hasbro Cinematic Universe as well so
let's get into it the film opens with a
narration by Optimus primal in Beast
Wars the maximals are futuristic
descendants of the Autobots thus Optimus
primal is named after the legendary
Optimus Prime it seems the maximals in
this film follow a similar origin story
Primal explains that he and the other
maximals use the transwarp key a
futuristic Tech that opens portals to
other worlds to narrowly escape Unicron
who is devouring their home planet their
leader ape link sacrifices himself so
that the other maximals can escape to
what appears to be prehistoric Earth as
Gorge annihilates a blink we can see the
emblems of his previous victims on his
shoulder pad on quick glance I noticed
the Predacon emblem and a maximal emblem
Scorch adds ape links emblem to his
trophies that bastard Primo is the new
leader and we are on our way psych
before we get into it don't forget to
check out the break room's discussion of
Transformers that video is linked in the
bio myself Corey jandro J Washington
talked all about the movie and where we
think the franchise is going we jump to
1994 in New York City there's an ad for
stomp on the taxi cab which began its
run in New York in February of 1994 and
it's time to meet our humans the human
element in these movies I think is
always tricky I think the 2007
Transformers and Bumblebee movies
handled it the best but there are a lot
of times I think the human story lines
in these movies kind of sideline the
Transformers and let's be honest that's
the action we want besides that the
Transformers already behave like humans
complete with complex emotions and
empathy the G1 cartoon had human
characters but in the end it was all
about those Autobots and Decepticons
okay and rant because I really did like
our two human protagonists first we meet
Noah played by Anthony Ramos AKA Phillip
Hamilton us Navi from In the Heights
that's right he's singing he's dancing
but not in this movie we're gonna look
at his room and boy oh boy is this room
decorated to remind us that it is the
90s there is of course a Puerto Rican
flag shouting out Noah's Heritage along
with posters of the Wu-Tang Clan the
female r b Trio SWV the notorious
b.i.g's Ready to Die album along with
the single for big papa and a big poster
of Nas pinned right above his desk we
see cassette tapes for De La Soul and
Diana Ross we see his dog tags letting
us know that Noah was in the military
his full name is Noah Leon Diaz he's got
B positive blood and he's Catholic so my
mom's gonna like this movie hopefully
God is on the side of the Autobots Noah
shows off his electronic skills by
rigging a Scrambler box to watch some
cable for free I may know where you can
get those in Niagara Falls and once it's
working we get a quick shot of the 1992
film juice during Tupac Shakur and Omar
Epps it's here that we also established
the radio he uses to communicate with
his younger brother Chris they use code
names Sonic and Tails from the Sonic the
Hedgehog video game that came out for
Sega Genesis in 1991. in the kitchen the
calendar on the wall lets us know that
it is June 1994 specifically there's a
Game Boy on the table and Noah is
wearing a neon air Jordan tank top That
I Used To Rock in my chubby little boy
body Chris is rocking a Power Rangers
t-shirt which is also on my hands bro
the Power Rangers are now in the Hasbro
portfolio so it makes sense to see them
here Chris is suffering from sickle cell
anemia and they're way behind on the
medical bills when Noah shows up for a
job interview we see a security guard
watching the O.J Simpson Bronco Chase on
TV it appears to be live which if that
is the case that would make this day
exactly June 17
1994. it was a good day after a failed
job interview Noah turns to his friend
reek played by Toby and wigwe for some
quick cash and by the way we hope Noah
would use some of that cash at nerd Ryan
our friends and merch Partners who make
this awesome Guardians of the Galaxy
album shirt that I'm wearing join the
riot over at nerd riot.shop okay back to
Noah in his Newfound short-lived Life Of
Crime he and Rick head to a fundraiser
full of rich people and fancy cars and
Noah manages to sneak into the garage
and swipe a sick Porsche the film's
director Stephen Caple Jr told Empire
magazine that choosing a silver and blue
Porsche 911 Carrera for Mirage was a
direct nod to Michael Bay who uses a
black Porsche 964 turbo in his film bad
boys of course Michael Bay directed a
few Transformers movies you may have
heard well those are a separate timeline
from these films it's a nice homage to
the director who originally brought the
Transformers into live action mirage's
Porsche Design is specifically a Porsche
911 Carrera RS 3.8 which was a European
exclusive model that only had 55 made in
total so yeah stealing this car would be
very valuable simultaneously Elena
played by swarms Dominique Fishback is
interning at a museum which gives her
access to ancient artifacts Elena is an
expert in authenticating artifacts
something her boss exploits for her own
personal gain see Elena identify an
authentic Da Vinci sketch which is
actually studies for the travolzio
monument some sketches he made around
1508 for a statue that was never built
along with the artifact she's asked to
identify as a curious Falcon sculpture
that she claims others have
misidentified nobody wants to listen to
The Intern she manages to sneak into a
locked room after hours to get a closer
look at the sculpture she scans it and
is able to trace it back to the Incas in
through also notice the cave drawings to
scan references the people depicting the
drawings are not afraid of the animals
which I think are the maximals rather
they appear to be listening to them the
drawings I think are cheetor rhinox
Optus Primal but no air razor indicating
they've been separated for some time
while investigating she accidentally
uncovers what we will learn as the
transwarf key or at least half of it the
key begins to set off a beacon of Light
which attracts the attention of Optimus
Prime not Optimus primal Optimus Prime
big truck okay thank you to better help
for sponsoring this video movies and TV
can be great escapism but when it's time
to face things head on better help is
here to help betterhelp is the world's
largest therapy service and is 100
online with better help you can tap into
a network of over 30 000 licensed and
experienced therapists who can help you
with a wide range of issues and trust me
baby I got a wide range to get started
just answer a few questions about what
you're looking for from therapy and what
your preferences are better help will
then match you with a therapist from
their Network that's right for you after
that talk to your therapist however you
feel comfortable whether it's via text
chat phone or video call I send a raven
you can message your therapist at any
time and schedule live sessions when
it's convenient for you if your
therapist isn't a right fit for any
reason you can switch to a new therapist
at no additional charge better help
gives you the same level of
professionalism and quality you expect
from in-office therapy but with a
therapist who is custom picked for you
more scheduling flexibility and at a
more affordable price and that's
important get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com new rockstars that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p.com Slash new
rockstars for 10 off your first month of
therapy give yourself the gift of
therapy meanwhile back in the garage
Noah's having second thoughts about
stealing a car but his attempts at
leaving are thwarted as the car comes to
life upon hearing Optimus Prime's
command to assemble this is no Porsche
baby this is Mirage voiced by Pete
Davidson and by the way he does an
amazing job he plays a great Autobot
reminded me of the 80s cartoons with the
quippy comments and a great comedic
delivery lay off me Davidson in this
movie guys he's a great Autobot there's
an awesome police chase that we saw in
all the trailers Mirage duplicates and
it also duplicates an image of Noah that
I do not think was included in the
trailer one point he flips the bird to
the police not a smart move Mirage
invades the police and heads to a
warehouse where we meet RC and Bumblebee
in a very pissed off Optimus Prime
remember this isn't your mid-2000s
Optimus Prime crying about protecting
humans this Optimist thinks humans stink
but there's that damn Beacon which leads
to the transwarp key and the Autobots
gotta go get it for someone bad does it
says it's a museum most Transformers
don't fit into door frames Mirage
volunteers know how to sneak in which
foreshadows the theme of humans being
needed to get into small spaces while
the Transformers do the heavy lifting by
the way Noah only agrees to help because
Mirage shows him he can turn into any
car and will let Noah sell him after he
completes his mission which is kind of
effed up if you ask me the Autobots
aren't the only ones who notice the
beacon has lit up Scourge nightbird and
battle trap make the most dramatic
Landing in the Hudson said Sully join
the race to find the beacon Optimus
reminds us they've been on Earth for
seven years which tracks with the
timeline established in Bumblebee which
took place in 1987 Heaven Scourge tells
optimists that Primus would be ashamed
Primus is the living Creator God of the
Transformer race whose body became the
planet Cybertron Primus is also the twin
brother of Unicron should have eaten him
in the womb after air razor saves the
day she and the surviving Autobots meet
up and she explains that she is a
maximal a Warrior from both your past
and future this is again in reference to
the time-betting nature of the maximal's
arrival on Earth she also mentions
Unicron which causes Optimus Prime to
react clearly Unicron has been a threat
for a long time to all Autobots she also
reveals that the key that Scourge and Co
escaped with is only half of the key and
the other half is hidden away for safety
Elena has identified the location of the
second part of the key and the plan is
set to travel down to Peru before they
leave Noah has to say goodbye to his
little bro but Mirage makes too much
noise and Chris discovers it Noah says
the giant robot is a friend from work
which Mirage blocks at and points out
that Noah's been inside him potentially
the most crass joke in a Transformers
movie ever but also probably
foreshadowing what's to come in act
three first we need to get to Peru how
are they getting there stratosphere baby
voiced by John DiMaggio my favorite
robot designed for bending Stratosphere
was previously seen in the old films as
a Lockheed C-130 Hercules but in this
movie he's a sputtering old cargo plane
and we also get to see him in robot mode
for the first time on film look at that
adorable aviator hat stratosphere is big
enough to fit the whole crew and we land
in Cusco Peru just in time for a giant
Festival also joining the gang in Peru
is wheel Jack this time voiced by
Christo Fernandez AKA Danny Rojas from
Ted lasso transforming his life his
exchange about racism with Noah is
really funny and also kind of a thinker
parade features a giant Rhino and a
cheetah and I believe an ape in the
background and I can't help but wonder
if this Festival is actually a
celebration of the maximals or at least
their Legend Optimus primal introduces
the Autobots to the tribe that has
guarded the other half of the transwarp
key for ages Primal tells Prime that
humans are more than BPI a nice inverse
of the usual slogan used to describe
Transformers Transformers
[Music]
Scourge connects the two sides of the
transworp key which creates a huge third
act portal machine inside a volcano
Unicron can finally begin his Ascent to
earth side note Coleman Domingo's voices
Unicron is incredible and he's filling
some pretty big shoes a previous voice
of Unicron was Orson Welles in
Transformers the Moon
an Unicron the max levels and Autobots
unite for the final battle and face off
against Scourge Mirage sacrifices
himself to protect Noah and we learned
that Noah's brother Chris has given
Mirage the nickname Knuckles a third
Sonic the Hedgehog character who first
appeared in Sonic 3. surprisingly Mirage
is only mostly dead and in a final Act
transforms into an exosuit around Noah
we've seen the EXO suits in the G1
cartoons Noah seems no match for Scourge
but Prime has his back it also slides in
in that break dancing pose I like it I
love that Prime fights dirty here Chuck
some lava and discourage his face like a
hero wrestler throwing salt into the
eyes of his opponent Scourge begs
Unicron for help and he obliges by
setting scorpionox but it's too late
Prime cuts off his arms and tears off
his head in the process the console
where Elena needs to enter the Safeguard
is destroyed as his tradition after his
prime offers to sacrifice himself by
destroying the key he breaks the key in
Unicron and all the surrounding Terracon
Tech is sucked back into the portal Noah
saves Optimus Prime and then those two
are saved by Optimus primal cementing
the bond between Autobots humans and
maximals Noah is reunited with his
family back in New York and he's back on
the job hunt he goes to another job
interview at slizza Imports and this
time the security guard is watching 60
minutes where we see Leslie Stahl
interviewing Elena who's being credited
for discovering the hidden Incan Village
beneath the church in Peru she's living
her dream during the interview Noah has
asked about his recent work in Peru
which he refuses to disclose but this
interview is more than meets the eye as
well he knows exactly what Noah has been
up to in Peru and who his big friends
are the man adjusts a real hero award on
the wall which reveals a secret facility
where they're building a futuristic
looking jet that could be a sky Striker
Noah discovers that this company is a
front for the GI Joes and they want to
join forces with the Autobots well no it
doesn't outright except the job it looks
like Hasbro is trying to launch a new
Cinematic Universe and I am here for it
the recruiter is listed as agent Burke
which could be a reference to the
character Matthew Burke a James Bond s
character who is featured in the GI Joe
cartoon episode The Spy Who rooked me
the post credit scene features Noah
showing reek what looks to be a Porsche
rebuilt with scraps the Porsche is of
course Mirage reek is now aware of
Transformers and I think Noah may be
putting a team together well what a ride
I definitely feel like the franchise is
on a cool path especially with the GI
Joe crossover they tease if you want
more of us talking Transformers we broke
it down in the break room the link to
that is in the description don't forget
to subscribe to the new break room
Channel we've got great secret Invasion
content coming up as well as all your
favorite break room hosts bits and
insane characters we're having fun over
there and we hope you'll join us don't
forget to check out our many great merch
options at nerdrive.shop follow me at
Tommy bechtold follow new rockstars on
all social platforms and be sure to
subscribe to our channel here on YouTube
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching roll out
[Music]
thank you